Bernie Sanders has suspended his 2020
Democratic presidential campaign
announcing it today to staff and then to
supporters on a call swirling questions
about how much longer his campaign would
go on and so a few different thoughts
and we'll have full coverage of this on
tomorrow's broadcast program number one
it was time to do it and I know that
there are people who have been emailing
emailing me saying Bernie should just
stay in until the last vote
he's very far behind nationally in every
state Bernie had no path to the
nomination for six weeks now a lot of
people have been saying the coronavirus
crisis is going to put Bernie in the
lead because people will realize that we
need Bernie not Biden because of the
vote coronavirus crisis none of the
polling has reversed its continued to go
further and further in Joe Biden's favor
so there was no mathematical case for
Bernie to stay in that's the reality now
Joe Biden needs to actually be very
publicly visible right now and of course
we're all under self-isolation that
includes Joe Biden he's staying home but
the sporadic interviews and weird
coronavirus briefings that he's been
doing are not going to cut it he is now
I mean he has been at this point for a
month but he is obviously now the
nominee and he needs to be out there and
he needs to be out there in a way that
is not self-destructive and there are
questions about to what extent Joe Biden
is going to be able to do that I don't
know how much we need to be paying
attention to early polls right now that
say here is Biden versus Trump in
Michigan or in Wisconsin so much of what
happens between now and November that
has nothing to do with Biden is going to
determine how close it's going to be
this includes how the economy does the
coronavirus response the trajectory of
coronavirus etc the best thing Bernie
supporters can do are you ready the best
thing Bernie supporters can do is to
lobby Joe Biden to move his platform to
the left and to support Joe Biden with
the understanding that we are not going
to give him a pass if he is the
president
but we are going to be on him the way we
are we were on Obama over economic
issues drone warfare on and on and on to
get as much as possible out of a
hypothetical Biden presidency now for me
there really is no moral question there
is no economic question there is no
environmental question there is no
social question Donald Trump cannot be
trusted to handle anything Joe Biden's
coronavirus response would have been a
real response and we would be far better
off today than we are Joe Biden's tax
plan is better than Donald Trump's Joe
Biden on the environment supports the
green New Deal as a framework Trump
thinks global warming and climate change
are a hoax created by the Chinese Trump
would Trump pulled us out of the Paris
climate agreement Biden would put us
back in it on the on any issue Joe Biden
is better does that mean Joe Biden's a
progressive hero no it does not period
and that is my understanding
Joe Biden would likely get to select a
number of important judges including
potentially one or two Supreme Court
justices during the next four year
presidential term I don't want anybody
being subjected to decades of whoever
Trump picks to replace Ruth Bader
Ginsburg making decisions on the Supreme
Court so there is no question this is
not vote blue no matter who it's vote
Biden over Trump it's not a blank check
to the Democratic Party I'm not even a
Democrat I don't care about the
Democratic Party I find it to be a
widely corrupt institution it is merely
a simple calculation
do I want Donald Trump to be president
for four more years or would I prefer it
be Joe Biden that is the only
alternative at this point in time the
answer for me is clear Bernie did the
right thing let's now see what kind of a
role Bernie can play in the rest of Joe
Biden's campaign